hey before we hit the news stories i
have something i have to bring up very
important
news you know people magazine's most
beautiful uh people issue
i do well you're in it oh hi
that is so crazy look at you
uh i have to say no one told me about
that
so you're just flipping through i was
just flipping through because i'm a big
people subscriber it's one of my
favorite magazines
and i was flipping through and then i
saw that and i thought well that's a
good
cool thing are you kidding me it's
beyonce if i was in this i would print
it out on a billboard and just walk
around with it
on me well thank you you're doing that
for me and i will do that for you
anytime
well ross it's almost oscar time and
this year the awards um
show for movies is going to feel like a
big
movie now this is really interesting and
this is really exciting and interesting
vanity fair reports that there's
no host no traditional presenters and
instead there's going to be a huge
ensemble cast of beloved actors
angela bassett rhys witherspoon regina
king
brad pitt harrison ford and zendaya
many more and they're going to appear in
character
what does this mean we don't know and
it's being produced by a trio of heavy
hitters including director steven
soderbergh
brilliant long time collaborator stacy
share and jessie collins who
just um produced the grammys which i
thought
really nailed it that's how you do a
show in the pandemic
i totally agree that was the benchmark
for me and quest love
is running all the music for the night
so they promised a cinematic love letter
to film
i am very intrigued i think this all
needs a spin right now i really do
yeah aha so it's a different time right
so the award shows gonna be different
and i hope they do it in a way that does
honor
the artists yeah because we needed art
to get through this
exactly there has to be a deeper uh
road into this well i'll be watching no
matter what oh
all right and from cinematic award shows
to cinematic marriage proposals
people reports a man named william hunn
took his girlfriend on a helicopter ride
around the city of atlanta
then they landed on a rooftop and he got
down on one knee and proposed but
the most shocking part about this is he
proposed with
five different rings yeah he gave his
bride-to-be brittany miller plenty of
options she said yes and she tried on
all the rings
and then she picked her favorite and you
gotta love a guy who knows how to
present options
i am a man who loves an option that's
why i love
buffets i'm also a man
it's true i'm also a man who just
proposed to somebody
and like it was the most nerve-wracking
thing
creating the ring picking the ring
because it's something that oh hi
you should wear this every day of your
life and i'm going to pick it out for
you the pressure was monumental
so you nailed it thanks for noticing i
did
you really did i've never seen a design
like that it's really unique
and while i was making it as i would
show drew pictures during the whole
process it was very fun but i felt a ton
of pressure
so i love this idea i absolutely love it
it totally speaks to a cute buffet i
actually hate buffets
now come on why you don't like
options i can't do it i it grosses me
out
not only do i love a buffet but i belong
to the casino in palm springs it's a
free membership but i get three dollars
off the buffet
so it's 11.99 and that doesn't i mean
beverages dessert all of it drew i mean
what's not to love
you take a trip around the world you
want spaghetti and an egg roll hello
buffet thank you i'm a buffet person
and i'm not going to just change my mind
with spaghetti and egg raw
yeah and you want you want some jello on
the walk back to your booth
buffet
wow okay well anyway all diamond
companies or
engagement ring proprietors i think that
this gentleman may start a revolution
i'm on board
um okay so if you don't have the money
for five diamond rings um what about
saying i love you with a nice
foot rub well it works for nicole kidman
glamour reports that nicole likey to
give her husband keith urban
a little love with an at-home pedicure
in fact she treats her whole family to
spa days
complete with foot massages my daughter
olive would love this story
as she has olive spa uh-huh which is
not the most hygienic spa in the world i
might ask what does she do she give you
pedicures and things
uh the works face masks jade rollers
she's
like a foot massager thing she had a
towel warmer she has a towel armor
i took it from her i was afraid she was
going to burn down the apartment
ross do you and your fiance ever trade
petties no god
no no i i mean i love him
i i would you know if you needed a foot
rub i would do it but i think there
should be some romance
you know i love his soul but i don't
want to scrape his souls
if i were to do that it would be quite a
feat
[Laughter]
well speaking of happy couples saturday
night live's pete davidson who come on
let's just face it we all are fascinated
with him totally well he might have a
new pedicure partner because
entertainment tonight reports that pete
was recently asked who a celebrity crush
was on a zoom interview and he answered
that he is
with his celebrity crutch fueling rumors
that guess what
ross what he is dating possibly
we don't know but bridgerton's
phoebe denver oh my god guess what last
month pete and phoebe were spotted
together in uk
near her hometown where she's been
quarantining with her mom holding hands
and then she took a trip to brooklyn and
was like
so nice to like hang out here so nobody
knows but it's all the little rumor buzz
okay we've never talked about this ever
but i am so fascinated by him
specifically
who he's dating right well i mean if you
look at all the ladies that he's had
courtships with
i mean all the it girls are goo gaga for
him i
know and he apparently according to
people who i know
know him and work with him say he is
this wonderful guy
i love hearing that and i also now
didn't know but i want him to guest on
bridgeton
right by the way i could see that like
bridgerton bridges all the genres so hey
um richardson and tunnel
[Applause]
[Music]
oh